There are, of course, hundreds of thousands dead
now in the United States from the coronavirus.
And Donald Trump has been completely silent
about that for months, although he is absolutely
furious that so many celebrities are going to
be performing in the Joe Biden inauguration.
It is immoral and inconceivable that this is what
Trump is focused on after his failure that led to
way more coronavirus cases and deaths than we
needed to have. Trump is furious that Lady Gaga
will be performing for Joe Biden. Trump is
furious that Jennifer Lopez and Tom Hanks
are going to be featured at Joe
Biden's inauguration tomorrow.
Donald Trump is furious that country singer
Garth Brooks, who refused to participate
in Trump's inauguration, although Brooke
said it was merely a scheduling conflict,
will be performing for Joe Biden tomorrow. Now,
Garth Brooks, listen, I don't know that much
about Garth Brooks, his politics. I don't know if
he's sort of like a Dixie Chicks country artist.
That is the rare progressive exception to what
is a more conservative area of music. I don't
know much about Garth Brooks. I don't know that I
believe it was merely a scheduling conflict four
years ago and that now he's doing it to unite the
country, as he says. Maybe that's the case. Maybe
scheduling conflict is just an excuse. But in any
case, Trump is furious and Trump is furious about
the A listers who shunned him. And he's furious
that now they are going to perform for Joe Biden.
And I think that the story here really is, is, you
know, I don't really care about the performances,
I think is the point. What I care
about is the following. It appeared
during Donald Trump's campaign and it was proven
during Donald Trump's presidency that Trump has
only ever cared about himself. The riots are
a perfect example. Trump never cared about the
rioters as supporters. I said this last week when
the rioters had the House and Senate cleared and
delayed the count of the electoral votes. Trump
was pleased because that's what he wanted to see
happen when it became clear that the rioters were
appearing to want to be careful in how I say it.
Trump's perception was that the rioters looked low
class. Trump was then mad. He never cared about
the rioters when they were useful and he never
cared about the rioters when they appeared low
class to him and were making him look bad.
And then when Donald Trump did that speech
saying all of the rioters will be and should
be prosecuted to the fullest extent of the law,
some people said, oh, he turned on his own
supporters. No, he didn't. He never cared
about them as anything other than tools useful to
him in achieving his political goals. That's it.
Full stop. And so that's what this is about.
Tragic numbers of coronavirus deaths. At
last count, the U.S. has surpassed four hundred
thousand coronavirus deaths. And what Donald Trump
cares about is how is the Joe Biden inaugural
going to look relative to the Trump inaugural
from the standpoint of celebrity participants?
Now, lucky for Trump and I say this sort of
tongue in cheek, who really cares about this? But
lucky for Trump, Joe Biden is not going to have
a national mall filled with supporters because
of the virus. Donald Trump on day one of his
presidency sent then press secretary Sean
Spicer out to lie about the size of Trump's
crowds. Trump's not going to be able to Trump is
not going to have to fight about that because Joe
Biden won't have a big crowd because there's a
pandemic and Joe Biden is doing the responsible
thing. But the lesson here is when it looked like
Trump only cared about himself his entire career,
when it looked like Trump only cared
about himself during his campaign,
when it looked like Trump only cared about
himself during his presidency, we were right.
That's exactly what it was. It's about gathering
wealth. It's about inflating his ego and feeding
his pride. And something very interesting is about
to happen sociologically to the Trump family.
Donald Trump and also his children are about to
realize how much everybody really dislikes them
in the circles they used to run in when he and
they start to be rejected from those very social
circles. New York City is not a cultural milou
that looks forward to welcoming Donald Trump. They
did accept him previously. They're not going to
now. And we've seen the New York City signs saying
no to Jared and Ivanka. We've seen Palm Beach
trying to stop Trump from doing the things he
wants to do in moving back tomorrow. Largo, half
the country is swearing off any of Trump's hotels
for life. It is going to be a real awakening
here. And, of course, Donald Trump is going to
blame others. We know that, but it's still going
to be something to see. Now, by the way, I don't
care about how celebrities. Relates to what's
going on with Trump, Biden a bit beyond what
it means for the culture of the country, but the
Garth Brooks thing really does crack me up only
because Garth Brooks did turn Trump down in 2017,
again, saying it was just a scheduling conflict.
And now Dr. Jill Biden asked Garth Brooks to
play and he said he's going to and he put out
a statement saying this is merely a statement of
unity. This is not a political statement. I want
the country to be united. But Trump very, very
triggered. And I can only imagine what is going
to happen as Donald Trump and his family try to
get back to normal life. And and remember, when
you understand Donald Trump's goals of placating
his ego and boosting his self-importance of being
president and alienating half the country and
many of the business and celebrity contacts that
he previously hung around with, it's going to be a
real awakening and I expect a very isolated Trump.
And the last thing on this, and I want to move
on this goes back to when I was talking about
Trump only cares about his supporters as as useful
political tools and nothing else. The people Trump
has spent a life wanting to associate with are
the elites in Manhattan, a powerful politicians,
global leaders and businessmen. In this
type of thing, Trump has spent a life
trying to not be around the people that are the
the vast majority of his voters. And so it's very
interesting that as Trump leaves office, the only
people that accept Trump are the people he spent
a life trying not to spend time around. Really
a sociologically a very interesting thing. So
will be with you for the Joe Biden inauguration
starting tomorrow at 11:00 a.m. Eastern. I want
to take a very brief break. And afterwards we're
going to talk about what will right wing media
look like for the next two years? We have a couple
of sort of I guess I'll call them early signals.
We're going to look at some interesting clips.
They may be surprising.
They may not, depending on how much attention
you've been paying or did pay to what right
wing media looked like under President Barack
Obama. Quick break. Right back after this.